have this drugs I'm entirely done and
I've even managed to bind it to this
controller there is some sort of
connection but I can't because it is
pouring rain what I did today was
bringing a bunch of racing drone parts
for this little tiny micro drum that I
have and I'm going to try to build it
but we'll see if that actually works
about this big super tiny so the problem
is I've never actually built a racing
drone before but I bought all the parts
so hopefully I can actually assemble
this into something that I can race next
door and mess with all those people tiny
little motors now we have our control
board here and this is actually the
brains of the entire drone itself it
looks like just any normal computer chip
so this tab is lemon tree stuff on here
we've got a tiny little radio here and
it will actually power the motors and
the camera would the size of this thing
here is a nickel right next to the
little fpv camera this is meant to take
a real live video signal from this tiny
little camera directly to my eyeballs
whoa look at all that stuff
okay I've never owned an RC boat I've
always been jealous as a child I go to
friend houses and some people look like
ants Williams one night I had a pool and
then they had a party boat they drive it
around in their pool and I was like ah
the street is completely flooded today
and we have these mini drones leftover
from a shoot we can they have these
little hydrofoil that should ride on
water you think it's going to be deep
enough
I don't know but fear what I know that
this terrible hook it's looking at all
those bees well how much water there is
okay I started putting this drone
together I managed to get the motors
installed in the right spot and I've got
the control board pressed on but I
haven't got the screws in yet I got a
well the camera first but my main issue
is although I know how to solder I'm not
particularly good maybe Spencer can
solder the phone because what we have to
do
cut the cable for this and then solder
it directly to these tiny little nodes
here and I don't quite trust my own
skills to slaughtering soldering skills
that's the one should I be bold and just
solder it myself or should I get
spinsters help my grandfather always
told me do it and I can find father
let's do it I don't think so little
nervous first things first attaching
this little fpv camera to the drone
moment of truth man according to that
image right there red on bottom black on
top the red is the power of the black is
the ground don't mess up
I won't in my past nature please work
please work please work
ah I got one on there now to do the
other and I state that I'm not very good
this yeah I think I got it
pick a guy we're going to put the liquid
tape the little dab on it you know what
electrical tape is this is essentially
that but in liquid form you know what
that's good enough
screw it I need a napkin did it die then
it's not connected hoping they're
waterproof drone is now proudly dead
could you fulfill your childhood fantasy
yeah I filled a brief ten seconds of
just glory I was on that little boat
sailing at a 5.8 not was it worth it yes
Plato you're going to get flashed why is
it so difficult everything should work
why won't it just work this is so
aggravating have the stroke pretty much
entirely done and I've even managed to
bind it to this controller so there is
some sort of connection but I can't
control the motor I just want to go
spoke to people next door light is
blinking turn on light so it that means
it should be connected now the problem I
ran into is that even though I was able
to bind this to my controller I wasn't
able to get the motors of learning
because there is a setting that I didn't
actually activate it seems obvious in
hindsight but I didn't have a switch set
to arm the motor I've now set that wish
so now the thing work
it's weird like walk around like this
okay okay here I come
video game view this is so weird
okay alright
maiden flight here in the studio this is
not easy to fly by the way okay coming
up to say hi
[Music]
guys
ix crashed upstairs I don't know if my
skill level is up to slang next door but
I'm going to try and like your
grandfather says what I haven't told any
of them that I'm going to do this so
let's go do some recon Hey here goes
nothing we great story all next door on
next door hey everyone
a person
[Applause]
now the real test is if you can get they
had a Brandon
[Music]
all right I'm in six
Oh
[Music]
I'm on camera
no just try to hit me
[Music]
ha
looks like Darrin please mr. McClory
[Music]
no God I'm trapped in a prison this is
probably Kevin do it sure you are
y-you do too and that my friend how you
mess with other Studios will focus will
do some good
yeah did until they trapped me in a hat
prison I didn't expect that I should
have in hindsight
now put a pink bow not doing them too
often on Kevin
middle I call that a success Nick it
took it more than a day but we got to it
in the end
thanks for for thanks grandpa
hereditary high five Arjun your goodies
in the whole thing I know whoa
what is it Tori hey Tony